the jurogan experience well there was
also
some pretty heavy moments in the
documentary the series where you
talk about yourself yeah and you talk
about your own experiences as
child being raped yeah which is
it was unexpected and very intense
and how difficult was that
to sort of express on camera well i'm
pretty comfortable talking about that
yeah about being yeah about being raped
when i was seven years old but it was
relevant to this show because it came up
like to your earlier point about the
sort of topics that or that
what a dark world it was up there right
and like like
why so it's like why am i drawn to those
kinds of stories and why have i spent so
much of my professional life
steeping myself in
dark worlds criminal subcultures right
so that was that was
that was why that particular part of my
my life story i think was actually
relevant to this
to this series but to answer your
question how difficult was it not
not very difficult it was difficult for
me to
go public with that story for the first
time which was in 2004.
i mean i'd lived with it as a secret
like pretty much my entire life
but the decision to write about it was
that was a very difficult decision a
very difficult thing to do
but between you know since then i've
i've gotten pretty comfortable talking
about it publicly i mean that story's
been
adapted as a play you know it's been
produced all over the world
yeah yeah it's called stalking the
boogeyman like i wrote it i wrote an
essay called stalking the boogeyman
that's kind of
when i went public with that i was uh
that i'd been raped
when i was seven and then i had then
planned to kill the guy when i was in my
early thirties
like that was the subject of the yeah of
the essay
and then that was adapted as a play it
was on you know
this american life and so
um i've gotten i've gotten comfortable
with uh talking about that over the
years were you were you approached by
law enforcement
when you kind of went public about
wanting to stalk this person
arrested he got arrested i got arrested
really yeah
after the after the uh the first essay
came out the cops
cops arrested me because i
i'd admitted stalking the guy and
planning to murder him i mean i'd
admitted to criminal behavior in in the
in the piece that was published had the
guy ever been prosecuted for what he did
to you no
no he was a juvenile when it happened
and also like
the statue of limitations it happened in
alaska the statute of limitations
expired and also
this you know that's my word against his
you know at that point i mean
so i have since gone to the police and
filed an official
police report um
but i mean i withheld his name in the
first piece
that i published and i let him know
because i mean i met with him in person
as part of the
reporting if you will of that piece
[Music]
um it's a pretty uncomfortable
conversation that
you know it's a pretty uncomfortable
conversation because i've been following
the [ __ ] guy for months
like planning to kill him and i didn't
tell him that when
he went how old were you at the time
let's see i was early 30s 32-33 and how
old was he then
how was he when it happened he was he
was at the
when it happened he was in his uh
late teens was still still a juvenile
though so 16 17.
um so he was a bit in his early 40s when
i was
stalking him and then when he and i met
how'd you meet him
how'd you arrange it well i sent him a
letter i sent him a letter
uh like i sent him a registered mail
letter a fedex letter
and i just made sure he was going to get
this letter and i knew he'd gotten it
and there was a couple of reasons for
that one is
by that time i'd planned to publish this
essay
and just for like legal reasons needed
to let him know that this was
i needed to give him a chance to comment
okay even though in the letter i didn't
tell him that i was planning to write
the piece i was just like
listen i remember what happened and you
and i need to meet
okay and if you don't respond this
letter i'm going to show up on your
doorstep and have a conversation with
your wife
so he responded like pretty quickly
and we set a meeting at a restaurant and
then i switched up the location
several times and we met on the 16th
street mall why did you switch up the
locations
i thought he might be dangerous you know
that's just like basic
sort of but you still met him like i
understand what is the purpose of
switching up the location i didn't want
him to be able to set up on the location
at all i didn't want
him to have other people waiting for me
there or if tim
and i frank i just wanted to keep him
off balance
the entire day so that he would be he
wouldn't he wouldn't have a
possibility to sort of arrange anything
okay so we met on the 16th street mall
which is a pedestrian mall in
in downtown denver and um
yeah i just yeah i mean that experience
obviously is
branded my memory pretty clearly you're
a big guy
what is he a big guy as well not really
no i mean he was
a lot bigger than me when i was seven of
course you know that was one of the
first things that crossed my mind is i
could just [ __ ] dismantle this guy
right but we just we walked around the
block a couple times and i had
talked while you were talking yeah and i
had i had a hidden
recording device in a bike courier bag
and a pistol
uh that i was carrying were you still
thinking about killing him
i knew i couldn't get away with it see i
i i planned to get away with it
yeah i think i would have gotten away
with it what did he say
he apologized he apologized
and you know he said that um
you know that he'd been that he'd been
sexually assaulted when he was a kid but
which is one of the most infuriating
things to me when child molesters
well let's call them what they are men
who rape children
when they put that out there as an
excuse or rationalization or
reason for their behavior because
that just infuriates me but he
apologized he said that it happened to
him when he was a kid
and he swore that it had only happened
with me that i was the only
person that he'd raped when that person
was a child right up and
like repeatedly and um i
i had been going back and forth on
naming him
in that essay and
i his telling me
that it i was the only one
in the end i decided not to name him
like up to when again to that point of
they have to take the story away from me
it was like
we were just like an hour from the print
deadline
and i still didn't know what i was going
to name him and my editor patty calhoun
at the westwood she was like just go
block yourself in a room for 30 minutes
write both endings and then just we just
got to pick one man
just like go with whichever one feels
right so i wrote one ending that ended
with his name
and one ending that ended with how the
essay actually ends which is
not naming him and him just sort of
disappearing into the crowd on the mall
and went with that one that one felt
right it felt like a better ending
and it also um it just kind of spoke to
a point that i want to make which is
that they
could be anybody you know and
uh i also wanted to get wanted to give
him the benefit of the doubt
wow you're a good man that's a powerful
thing to be able to forgive someone for
such a horrific act
i'm not sure i have forgiven him well
enough to not name him
yeah that's just to give him that
that's a lot catch new episodes of the
joe rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience